I'm so disappointed because I just don't
think I can do this anymore [Music]
but I feel like it's gonna be a journey and
at the end of the road it's gonna be great
I'm 35 years old and I was just diagnosed
with ADHD so come with me on the start
of my latest health Journey because I
think this one is gonna change my life
[Music]
foreign [Music] welcome to my Vlog if you caught
my video a few weeks ago I was recently diagnosed
with ADHD and it finally feels like all of the
tiny little pieces of my mental health Journey
are finally coming together but before I get into
the Vlog definitely check out my disclaimer this
is not medical advice this is just my journey if
you suspect that you have ADHD please speak to
your health care provider and if you do have
ADHD also speak to your health care provider
everyone's experience especially around medication
is going to be unique also a heads up that I will
be talking about drug dependency and stimulants
so please skip this video If that is triggering
to you okay hold up for a second I want to tell
you about today's sponsor element so I'm really
honored to be working with element because this
is a product that I was using years ago when I
was on my breastfeeding Saga and it really really
helped me recover I ended up getting back into
it when I spent a few months down south this year
because because I just have a really bad tendency
to get heat stroke or get super dehydrated in
the Sun so this really saved me a lot of my
colleagues who work in sports and nutrition also
swear by elements specifically because it has a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of a thousand
milligram sodium 200 milligrams potassium and
60 milligrams magnesium and it has no colors
sugar or fillers I've also found the having my
electrolytes in the morning has also had a huge
impact on my sleep so even on days that I'm not
sweating a lot I'll usually still have at least
half a packet I love all things spicy so the mango
chili is my current Obsession but they have nine
different flavors including their new grapefruit
which I also really love right now element is
offering my viewers a free sample pack with any
order so that is eight single serving packets for
free with any element order and this is a really
great way to try all eight flavors or to share
element with a salty friend so you can get yours
at drinkelement.com Abby sharp and this deal is
only available through my link so you got to go to
d-r-i-n-klmnt.com slash ABI Sharp
hmm so good all right kids I'll catch you on
the other side I said I wasn't gonna medicate
like I told myself that getting this diagnosis
was just going to be like a good to know like
a validation basically of everything that I've
gone through all of my life up till now and it
has been it's been so validating but I just came
to this realization of how beneficial like how
life-changing medicating for my anxiety and my
insomnia has been like my biggest regret at this
point in life is that I didn't do it earlier and
so I guess I'm just curious what medicating for
ADHD will do for my life what doors could this
open for me so I'm going to take the plunge
wish me luck all right it is day two on Vyvanse
uh I woke up with like a little bit of a head cold
which is like why it is summer why am I getting
sick uh but let me tell you where I'm at so
basically I can see why people love this stuff
because I am in the best mood despite feeling
kind of I don't think I've ever felt this level of
mental calmness and energy at the same time it's a
very strange juxtaposition but I love it that said
I am tragically constipated and normally when I'm
constipated it is like the end of the world I
am so cranky I'm so irritable I'm so triggered
because of my history with sibo and you know the
fact that I have come so far on my IBS and just
like healing my gut and supporting my gut and I'm
in a really good place normally so when I do feel
like I'm off my usual bathroom routine I like
I am an anxious wreck but what today somehow I
feel just like more nonchalant about it like I'm
like I'm at peace with the fact that I can't poop
yeah I might feel a lot crankier later when I
kind of come down from this high and also when
I get a little bit more bloated and uncomfortable
but for now I'm going to channel this energy and
take myself for a little waxy all right it is day
five of me taking Vyvanse and I've got a lot of
thoughts and a lot of updates so first of all
I really love how it makes me feel some of the
times in some ways like when I first wake up in
the morning I have so much energy I'm in such a
good mood like I I love my kids I love my husband
the whole day is going to be an amazing day like
I don't know I'm in I'm vibing with myself
is you doing a good job [__] you're doing
a good job and I I've really haven't felt
like that in a really long time slash ever
um normally I move through the morning in such
a chaotic frantic way like I'll make the kids
breakfast and I just can't bring myself to like
put it away it just feels like there's just too
much going on I just remember doing a vlog one
time where somebody made a comment like it's
so messy you're so chaotic everything's a mess
and I'm like yeah it is messy like my whole the
way I think is messy wow this is a weird look
but I did I let my hair air dry today which
I never do so that was mistake number one like I
normally feel like a little bit of a tornado just
moving through the day and now I feel like I can
actually make the kids breakfast and put things
away and tidy up and manage them and interact
with them and be in a good mood and not be cranky
Etc also I was reading my son a book on the
Titanic this morning which is something this
is a book that I have read maybe three or four
times in the past two weeks so this is not like
a new book for me and for the first time I found
myself as I'm reading this being like oh I didn't
know that that's what happened oh that's you know
who took the call oh that's how it first smashed
into the iceberg Etc like I was actually learning
what happened for the first time even though I had
read the story a million times before so it's not
that I just like had short-term memory loss and I
blanked out it was that all the times before that
I read this book I was just seeing the words and
regurgitating them but not actually obtaining
any knowledge this was the first time that I
actually obtained Knowledge from what I've read
how have I managed to be so successful how was
I such a great student like I graduated literally
top of the class of all time like I just realized
how much mental energy I've spent over the past 35
years just to obtain enough knowledge in order for
me to have the success that I've had and it has
like shook me to my core that had I come to this
realization or being diagnosed 10 to 20 years ago
how much further could I have gone because I feel
like I've done a lot in 35 years and I'm really
smart but had I been able to concentrate better
when I was in school when I was an internship
when I was learning to become a dietitian I
would have been able to become smart without it
[__] almost killing me because that is what
school and education did to me it drove me into
the ground so that's good another unusual perk
that I'm experiencing is that I'm not remembering
my dreams which might seem like not a good thing
for you guys who like dreaming but my dreams are
so intense and Vivid and often really terrifying
who are you um and I dream many of them that I
often say to my therapist that I feel like I live
a whole other life at night and if you can imagine
when you're supposed to be resting at night living
a whole other life with people who may or may not
be in your real life it is exhausting and I wake
up every morning very exhausted and not rested
even though I may sleep eight hours and the past
few days I've woken up and I've not remembered my
dreams or I've remembered it so vaguely that it is
not significant it's not weighing on me it's I'm
not thinking about it all day long I think about
my dreams normally until I go to bed the next that
that night again and it starts all over again so
it's like I I work really hard in the day and then
I work really hard at night and I feel like maybe
my brain is relaxing finally enough that I can
rest when it's time to go to bed so that is that
is life-changing in itself so yeah that was the
good but there's bad as well there are things that
I do not like about this so far at least uh one
the constipation I was not I was not warned about
the constipation the other thing that I feel a
little uneasy about is just my fear of dependence
because you know I was taking between 20 and 30
milligrams and yesterday I took just 10 milligrams
because it was a day off and my goal here was to
be able to take the medication during the weekdays
when I need to feel concentrated and get my work
done and then the weekends not take it because
that's what a lot of my friends and colleagues who
take ADHD medications are able to do but I even
took 10 milligrams yesterday to try to hopefully
like get my digestion back on track and I have to
be honest I felt fully depressed I felt like I was
walking through mud all day super sluggish just
not like myself so that to me is really concerning
I don't like the way that feels I would rather
feel no high at all than to feel like in a dark
dark place when I don't take the medication and
this has only been five days so I am legitimately
concerned about that but I'm gonna go eat my kiwis
now and I will check back in with you guys later
okay so I spoke to my dietitian Caitlin self she's
amazing I'll leave her contact below um about
my symptoms and one of the interesting things
that she said is that in her experience one of
the main reasons for constipation with the folks
that she sees on Vyvanse is because they're not
eating enough because a lot of ADHD medications
these stimulants they can suppress appetite and
when we're not eating enough it can slow down our
gut motility and I already know this I've talked
about this ad nauseam in relation to why we see
more functional gut disorders when it comes to
eating disorders interestingly I haven't noticed
any impact on my appetite yet though obviously I'm
taking a very low dose still so that might happen
um so I don't think that I'm under eating and if
anything I probably am eating more than normal
because I'm kind of like throwing all my you know
my anti-constipation uh Foods at me so I'm bulking
up on a lot of high fiber foods lots of nuts and
avocados and lots of fruit and whole grains and
things like that so I'm kind of thinking more
about adding more foods to my diet right now
than I am about taking them away even if I'm not
particularly hungry so I don't think that's my
issue but if you do find that you've lost your
appetite as a result of taking a stimulant which
is very common here are some really quick tips
in terms of making sure that you're meeting your
nutrient needs number one set a meal and snack
schedule so this is really important for kids but
also very important for adults so if that means
you need to put an alarm on to remind yourself to
eat even though you may not have those hunger cues
really super important because as you get used to
the schedule your body will adapt and it'll start
to anticipate that fuel coming and you'll start
to get those hunger cues back number two small
frequent meals around every three or four hours
and this is also really important for nausea which
is something that I feel I'm getting like a little
bit nausea but it's not extreme or debilitating in
any way but for some people it definitely can be
so small frequent meals really key as opposed to
having like intermittent fasting and then having
a big meal not recommended when you've got low
appetite and then finally we want to focus on low
volume high calorie meals and snacks so you know
things like oh Poppy I gotta go get her one sec
so yeah focus on those higher calorie foods that
are lower in volume so as opposed to having like a
really big low calorie salad I want you to think
about peanut butter toast and you know protein
smoothies with nut butter in there and trail mix
and things like that that are going to be able to
eat very easily without a lot of volume also a lot
of people find that their appetite is a lot better
in the evening as opposed to the morning oh she
we've discovered that she gets freaked out when
I'm like talking to a camera because she's like
who is she talking who is she talking to she's
like she thinks I'm yelling at someone having an
imaginary conversation so that's why she's always
barking at me right it's not because you want
to to eat though that's also a possibility but
anyways um yeah a lot of people find that their
app tastes better in the evening so definitely try
to capitalize on that by having a large dinner and
a bedtime snack get that bedtime snack in there
um I want to show you what I'm making so let's see
so I'm going to make myself a little poo promoting
um uh snack here a little smoothie this is
something that Caitlyn recommended and I was like
this is a great little combination so let me show
you what I'm going to do see when I go on my team
here things are not always so well produced I got
celery juice you guys know how I feel about that
and you know how I always say that if celery juice
detoxes you it's because it's got so many fodmaps
in it that it helps to get things moving out of me
like lava we're gonna do some celery juice never
something that I would want to consume on its own
so kiwi we know has lots of research to suggest
that it can help with constipation and bloating
this is a massive kiwi so I'm only going to use
one but usually the clinical doses too but this
is this is a Honker I've got some pear here that
I cut up yesterday a little honk of cucumber this
is the ground so it doesn't like get as gelatinous
I'm not even going to peel it I'm just gonna throw
it in like that all right let's see how this goes
[Applause] okay guys you got
the picture I blended it up
this is what it looks like it's
not pretty but let's have a taste
mmm that is good I never think to put kiwi in
a smoothie but it works it's so like Tangy and
zingy it really works with the ginger I definitely
can get on board with this and I like that it's
not gloopy like chia pudding all right I'm gonna
go down this and hope that it gets things moving
and since we're on the topic of food I figured I
would hop in here really quickly to briefly talk
about foods to focus on and what to avoid when
it comes to ADHD so this is definitely an area
of research that's still evolving so take some
of this with a grain of salt but it is worth
experimenting to see what works best for you
so the big ones we typically hear about are
reducing artificial food dyes and excess sugar
I'm generally pretty cautious about food dyes
in our house since I noticed when I was a little
girl that I was kind of sensitive to them they
actually give me a bit of a rash so I've just
personally always avoided buying things with
food dyes outside of like special occasions
like birthday cakes and things like that
um otherwise I don't usually serve them to myself
or to my kids but there is some evidence that food
dyes can exacerbate symptoms in folks with ADHD
there's also some evidence to support reducing
some preservatives like sodium benzoate which is
usually found in things like soda store-bought
sauces condiments things like that plus nitrates
which you typically find in things like bacon and
deli meats but honestly I don't think we need
to obsess over every single packaged food that
we eat I think if we just focus on limiting
highly processed foods which I generally do
we can typically reduce the risk also on the
topic of Highly processed Meats one of you did
find that a diet high in saturated fat may also
increase the risk of ADHD so mainly that means
animal fats like high fat Dairy high fat meat Etc
personally I don't really eat a lot of red meat
and the dairy that I choose is fermented dairy
like yogurt cottage cheese and that's only like
five percent fat so those are things that are not
typically a concern for me and then there's sugar
so whether or not sugar causes hyperactivity is
like super controversial but one review found that
it may increase the risk in kids with ADHD even
though the evidence is weak at best interestingly
one of the common symptoms of ADHD is like sugar
Cravings or sugar addiction basically because we
need a bigger dopamine hit to feel the effect
of those pleasurable things I actually used to
describe myself as having a really really severe
Sweet Tooth but now I think that intuitive eating
and food Freedom has really suppressed that
or maybe it's just like age but yeah I don't
personally feel like I want to eat all the sweets
anymore you'll also see that there's a lot of
talk online about avoiding artificial sweeteners
if you have ADHD though there really isn't any
good evidence to support that at this time I would
say that if you are sensitive to them I feel like
it's an easy thing to remove personally I already
avoid things like Splenda and aspartame and other
artificial sweeteners mainly because they're not
great on my gut and I tend to get headaches from
them and I just don't like the flavor of them
so I may personally be sensitive but I'm already
cognizant of that and have basically removed them
from my diet so those are the things that you'll
read most often about reducing the diet when it
comes to a protective effect we know that a diet
rich in fruits and vegetables seems to be the best
bet surprise surprise so like this is not rocket
science folks it doesn't take rocket appliances
eat fruits and vegetables avoid highly processed
foods and additives focus on higher fiber carbs
over the really higher sugar ones and choose more
unsaturated fats over saturated I'm doing all
of those things and have been for years so yeah
nothing really to see here folks another thing we
can talk about though is the commonly recommended
supplements for ADHD so this is my supplement bin
I don't take all of these or all at once but I do
have them all in hand for different times of my
life so the first one that's often recommended for
ADHD is iron because some research does show
that iron supplementations can improve ADHD
symptoms though obviously you'd want to do blood
work first to determine if this would be helpful
for you my iron levels have always been really
good so I don't need iron at this time at least
zinc is another one and this is one that I do
personally take every day and this is because
it can help regulate the normal Pathways of
chemical Messengers in the brain so that's
another one to maybe look for in your blood work
next is Omega-3s which I already take we have
evidence that supplementing with Omega-3s may
help to improve symptoms since Omega-3s help to
reduce oxidative stress and improves that chemical
messenger Transmission in the brain also vitamin D
and this is one that I recommend most people take
because half of us are already vitamin D deficient
and we specifically have evidence that can help
with ADHD symptoms and then magnesium which oh
here she is this is one of my favorite supplements
that I take personally apparently people who have
ADHD tend to have lower magnesium in the body than
those who don't have ADHD so supplementation can
help ADHD symptoms and it can also help with
insomnia and anxiety which tend to coexist in
folks with 80 HD so I'm going to finish chopping
up some fruit for lunch and then I'm going to fill
in my pill packs for the week and I'll catch up
with you guys soon I'm so disappointed because
I just don't think I can do this anymore like
I'm on such a low dose and yet the crash by the
end of the day is so unbearable like last night
I was running a bath for my kids and I was trying
to say the word cold but instead I said black
down and Moon like I can't even form a sentence
I was talking to my doctor and I couldn't even
form a sentence so like my brain is obviously
not working very well when I come down off this
thing and like my gut is telling me that this
is not good for me that this is like a slippery
slope for me that this might be doing more harm
than good but my rational mind is saying you know
you got to try this out you gotta see it through
this is a process every you know psych drug is
always a process and it's never a fun process
right these Journeys suck and they especially
suck and feel especially hard at the end of
the day when I'm like at a low I don't like this
feeling I don't like feeling depressed which is
kind of where I am right now but I'm just
trying to take this one day at a time
okay I have to end this video on a positive
note I cannot believe you guys hang in here but
I have a plan and I feel really good about it so
basically I did a quick little Switcheroo to buy
Fenton instead of the Vyvanse so it's a different
class of ADHD medication um and I definitely found
it was a lot better in the sense that I wasn't
getting as extreme highs and lows um and I also
didn't find that it was causing me to be as
constipated so that was a huge plus that said
you know I still didn't feel 100 like myself and
I do think that that just is a matter of you know
me kind of recalibrating and taking time but I
basically only took two doses of it and my husband
just let me know that he's going on a little trip
for four days so I'm gonna be alone with the kids
for a few nights and honestly I just don't feel
comfortable with that knowing doing that this
drug is still making me feel a little bit dizzy
I'm not feeling like 100 100 myself I'm sleeping
better which means I may or may not wake up if
the kids are screaming for me or if they need me
I'm not sure I'm able to drive them somewhere in
the middle of the night if we have an emergency
Etc so for that reason I just decided okay I'm
gonna take a pause on this um and unfortunately
because my husband as soon as he gets home
we're going straight to the UK which is also
not a great time to start a new medication from
scratch considering all the different variables
I thought all right we know that this is possibly
going to change my life but I have to wait I have
to wait for it to change my life because I've
got too many other variables going on that is
not my normal routine so I'm gonna pick this whole
journey up again when I get back from all of my
holidays in the fall and I think that that's just
a better move that way I can kind of utilize its
benefits When I need the most as opposed to when
I'm on holidays just chilling out with my kids so
I'm really good about this plan I know I've had a
little taste I like the taste even though there's
some spicy bits in there but I feel like it's
gonna be a journey and at the end of the road
it's gonna be great signing off well kids another
stage another struggle but I hope you guys enjoyed
this Vlog I will definitely keep you updated
on the next phase of my journey if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs up if
you have specific questions about my journey or
about ADHD in general definitely leave me a
comment below and I will try to get to them
in an upcoming video subscribe to this Channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]